je t'aime je t'aime je t'aime je t'aime
des fruits paris je t'aime je t'aime
what i love you
viens de m'en tire un petit peu date en
sérieux fais-moi des promesses
délirantes
après tout qu'à voir si tu changes bien
me tromper
un petit peu raconte-moi l'énorme couac
qu'importe si je peux marquer
ne fera pas si
ma vie à l'envi
et c'est la fin
et
viens de me faire rire dans ce sublime
dont sinistre fait mollet farce
astronomiques
tout qu'importe si ça pique il peut
faire dire des conneries
alors
dicko
honneur chance
de toute façon est un malentendu
oui
rester toute façon été forcée
pourquoi dire la vérité
de la cei
pas tout à fait né vient on
on va s'y croirait
on ferait une danse giratoire
je dis pourquoi resté pendu façon rien
blais
m
merci sa peau